What happens when 800 of the world’s most elite footballers
and their managers live together under one roof?
Players stop being polite
and start getting Real.
This is
The Champions
People say I lack focus
I say
focus on THIS
Rules are meant to be broken
so is Mo Salah
I’m not here to make friends
I’m here to make history
I’m not here to make friends either
but if I did make a friend
that’d be nice because I’m a bit lonely at Real
At first I thought it was a language barrier thing
but now I speak some Spanish
and still nobody sits with me on the bus
I've been with Barca most of my life
It’s more than a football club
it’s really more like a
family
Since Don Andres left
it’s important that I step up as the emotional leader of this team
Sh-sh…don’t cry
He’s afraid he’ll have to play a La Liga match in America
It’s my job to make sure all the players on the team are happy
Like I’ve noticed Messi has been a bit down since the World Cup
I think he realizes he’ll never win a World Cup with Argentina
So I thought it would be fun to take Messi
and the rest of the squad to a pottery class!
If he can’t WIN a World Cup
he can MAKE one!!!
So, I’m making a Latin Grammy for mi amor
Shakira
She collects them
When are you going to give it to her?
Whenever, wherever
What are you making, Malcom?
Oh, I’m making Rakitic
Oh wow, the likeness is uncanny
You guys, you guys, look
see how happy he is
Leo
hold up your World Cup so I can take a picture of you with it
No, Pique, it’s not for me
It’s for Cristiano
Of course!
He’s not sad about Argentina
he’s sad because he misses Ronaldo in La Liga!
Without the Joker, there’s no Batman
Without Frazier, there’s no Ali
Without Russian sports, there’s no Anti-Doping Agency
These things need each other
I’m very excited to give Ronaldo my gift
Dear Cristiano
we had so many epic Clasicos together
but this will always be how I remember you
What is
Nooooooo!!!
Lionel!! You dog!
Ahahahahaha!!! Suck my ball.